[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france24 el
caribe será la sede del primer women
economic forum enfocado en la región un
encuentro que se realizará en un formato
virtual y que se enfocará en el
liderazgo y el empoderamiento femenino
con el objetivo de aportar a la equidad
de género entre la academia la empresa y
el estado además el acceso a las
conferencias será gratuito vamos a
conversar sobre las temáticas
específicas y sobre cómo estos espacios
pueden plantar semillas por los derechos
de las mujeres
para entrar en materia veamos los rasgos
de esta serie de conferencias con sede
en puerto rico pero adaptadas a la
virtualidad de por cuenta de la pandemia
el objetivo es que las mujeres seamos
vistas como una fuente de desarrollo y
de prosperidad para la región cuando nos
pide una plataforma solo para mujeres
para empoderarlas a ellas ya sus
comunidades ese número económico forma
caribbean digital 2021 reúne a líderes
de 40 países en ámbitos empresariales
políticos y sociales para impulsar la
equidad de género a través del
emprendimiento femenino busca promover
alianzas desde los gobiernos el sector
privado y la sociedad civil que
entiendan la diversidad y que se
expandan las oportunidades de negocio a
través de nuestra agenda buscamos
fomentar la auto confianza de las
mujeres en sus talentos para que
trasciendan como agentes de cambio
importantes influenciadores en sus
comunidades con más de 50 masterclass se
espera la asistencia de más de 30.000
participantes del caribe y del mundo
en el mundo las mujeres aparecemos sobre
representadas en sectores o mal pagos y
la pobreza nos golpea primero que a los
hombres en estas condiciones a alcanzar
la igualdad parece casi una utopía de
ahí la importancia de espacios como este
están con nosotros en ella soy yo ana
salgado directora de women economic
forum para el caribe y también janire
braña directora de me de community una
organización internacional sin ánimo de
lucro que se dedica a promover
emprendimiento de las mujeres
bienvenidas a ellas hoy comienzo
preguntando cómo es que espacios
académicos como este foro en el caribe
pueden ayudar a romper los ciclos de
pobreza de las mujeres comienzo con
ustedes johanna
bueno porque para nosotros es muy
importante trabajar en todo lo que tiene
que ver con la mentalidad y la cultura
esa es la primera forma para poder hacer
cambios y poder generar sobre todo
nuevas habilidades en las mujeres para
que ellas sean agentes multiplicadores
puedan generar oportunidades y también
sobre todo mirar qué es lo que necesita
la economía y ellas puedan generar
negocios que les permitan trascender sus
fronteras y mejorar su calidad de vida
janire usted es la mujer de los datos
cuéntenos o una mujer que está presente
como pieza clave de la economía
efectivamente hace que los países se
desarrollen por qué y cómo es que los
gobiernos todavía no se han dado cuenta
de que ese es el camino estamos muy que
dados todavía en políticas incluyentes
bueno yo creo que los gobiernos ya son
conscientes yo creo que todas las
personas hoy en día nadie puede negar
este efecto y especialmente después de
lo que hemos vivido con la pandemia que
es una necesidad real que las mujeres
son sido las poblaciones más afectadas
están entre las más afectadas por las
situaciones que hemos vivido y en una
situación de vulnerabilidad o es
importante existen una necesidad
importante de cerrar brechas no solo a
nivel social sino a nivel empresarial es
verdad que está creciendo el número de
emprendedoras en algunos países pero
todavía existe una brecha importante en
muchísimos países de latinoamérica y el
caribe esa brecha de género que se ve
reflejado especialmente en algunos
sectores como aquellos sectores más
relacionados con ciencias con energías
verdad con con tecnologías también se
ven reflejados en el mundo de la
política y en el mundo entorno social
que al final afecta a las familias no
obviamente a la sociedad pero también a
la economía
uno de los países quisiera seguir
hablando de eso pero ahora le pregunto a
johanna por qué proteger a una mujer es
evidentemente la mejor lucha que existe
contra la pobreza ustedes lo han dicho
en algunas declaraciones previas a este
foro que el 80% de los ingresos de las
mujeres van a sus familias y a sus
comunidades y yo lo he repetido en este
programa infinitas veces que proteger a
una mujer es proteger todo lo que está
detrás todas sus redes familiares y
sociales háblenos de eso
si efectivamente nosotros creemos que
para que haya cambios en la sociedad es
bien
importante poder empoderar a las mujeres
desde la parte también económica como lo
dices el 80 por ciento del salario de
las mujeres van dirigirse directamente
hacia sus familias y las comunidades
entonces ahí es donde nosotros vemos que
esta clase de plataformas pueden generar
inspiración para que otras mujeres
también se puedan dedicar a crear sus
propios emprendimientos y sobre todo que
tanto la banca como los gobiernos puedan
aportarle o invertir nosotros decimos
que es que invertir en una mujer es una
inversión inteligente social entonces
por eso queremos que más mujeres puedan
tener acceso a una mejor calidad de vida
no sólo para ellas sino para todos
y además sé que son muchos temas los que
se van a enfocar en este foro uno de
ellos es el bienestar cómo van a manejar
o cómo van a desplegar este tema
teniendo en cuenta el contexto de
pandemia que vivimos y que nos pega más
a las mujeres
si efectivamente como lo como lo
mencionaba janire el tema de la pandemia
ha afectado a las mujeres sobre todo que
están en áreas como el turismo el
comercio las manufacturas entonces es
pues parte lo que nosotros quisimos con
este foro es también agregarle dos
temáticas nuevas como es el tema del
bienestar y la salud para nosotros poder
empoderar a las mujeres también
significan que desde su ser puedan
empezar a generar nuevas fortalezas y
sobre todo enfrentar esta pandemia que
solo no solamente física sino mental
está llevando o afectando a las mujeres
en este en esta en estos años y quisiera
seguir en la misma línea con jane eyre
en el tema de los derechos de la mujer y
está conciencia que usted nos dice ya
existe en los gobiernos sobre las
necesidades que tenemos nosotras cómo
van entonces las agendas cómo avanzan en
el caribe y en américa latina asia una
revisión del tema de derechos humanos
bueno lo importante yo creo que en este
evento es que existen entidades del
ámbito al final del tercer sector como
es la nuestra que es organizador de este
evento pero también existe la labor de
las entidades de políticas de gobiernos
de diferentes países que se junten de
entidades multilaterales y de empresas
del sector privado que estén apostando y
apoyando espacios como éste que son muy
relevantes para escuchar para conocer
para inspirar y para generar
oportunidades económicas en la mujer
pero también para conocer las últimas
tendencias en torno a temáticas de
rabiosa actualidad como es el tema como
muy bien es mencionar a salud y
bienestar pero también el tema de
innovación el tema de las ciencias el
tema de la educación porque al final no
nos olvidemos que todo empieza desde la
educación desde la cuna desde las
familias y obviamente el enfoque desde
el punto de vista desde la en la empresa
y el enfoque económico porque al final
es la visión lo que queremos generar ese
ese compromiso por parte de todos los
actores con las mujeres para generar las
oportunidades económicas
en diferentes aspectos en diferentes
sectores y en diferentes entornos que se
vean beneficiadas ellas y sus familias
entonces en este sentido yo creo que es
un tema amplio pero aquí se va a tratar
de una forma muy concreta muy real y de
la mano de las personas que referentes y
expertas en estas temáticas que acabo de
mencionar no claro y algo que le voy a
conceder es que la primera cosa que uno
tiene que hacer para conseguir esto es
hablarlo entonces de ahí que sean tan
valiosos estos espacios de charla que
además son gratuitos de eso vamos a
hablar más adelante por ahora joan a
ustedes le apuestan a decir que esta es
una generación más compasiva esto es
algo al menos para mí es algo nuevo
háblenos el por qué por qué enfocarnos
en esto
bueno prácticamente el evento se llama
trascender es la primera vez que
nosotros hacemos un foro de um en
economic forum quien no habla solamente
de del empoderamiento de la mujer cuando
nosotros decimos trascender es porque
también hacemos una llamada para que los
hombres también sean partes y haga parte
de la construcción de una nueva economía
basada en la mujer cuando nosotros
hablamos más compasiva con
características de una sociedad
colaborativa es porque nosotros nos
hemos dado cuenta que en este tema de la
pandemia
nosotros nos volvimos hermanos sin
importar de qué país éramos o de qué
estratos sociales éramos su política
sino nosotros nos unimos para poder
generar
sobrevivencia y sobre todo fuentes de
desarrollo económico porque a todo a
todo el mundo le tocó la pandemia
entonces así como la revolución digital
llegó también la trascendencia del ser
hacia trabajar en equipo en colaboración
también llegó para quedarse y esto es
una nueva sociedad donde estamos creando
sobre todo alianzas y ccoo creación en
pro de la mujer
y finalmente janire ya para cerrar con
usted
las mujeres según el informe se siente
desde oxfam y de lago no somos las más
empobrecidas las peor remuneradas
estamos presentes en las tareas más
precarias del mercado y esto empeoró aún
más con la pandemia entonces cuál es la
radiografía que ustedes quieren
presentar dentro del foro bueno te falta
algún dato yo creo que es muy relevante
todo lo que has mencionado es real pero
también hay datos y están más que
probado que las mujeres tienen una
capacidad una resiliencia una capacidad
de gestión del cambio de recuperación y
al final de impactar la sociedad que es
única en este sentido también existen
muchos datos de entidades financieras
que hablamos de la buena gestión de
mujer de la mujer en lo que es de la
gestión de los recursos económicos y
financieros desde el punto de vista de
los ratios de morosidad de las entidades
que lo pueden confirmar entonces yo creo
que también ahí tenemos y como muy bien
ha dicho con joana que trascender con un
rol y con una
responsabilidad e impacto social que
pueda ser capaz de asumir un rol la
mujer de transformación del liderazgo
pero con un impacto social económico y
medioambiental que responda a todos los
retos globales en la actualidad
derivados del cambio climático de la
inequidad y la desigualdad que existe
social y económico en la en la
actualidad
muchísimas gracias janire y para el
cierre joana nos quedan a más o menos 20
segundos del programa simplemente le
quiero pedir que nos cuente cómo se
puede la gente inscribir para participar
en este foro
bueno pues a todas las personas que nos
están viendo los invitamos a que se
conecten a nuestras redes sociales web
caribe o west caribbean en instagram
facebook y twitter y en nuestra página
web west caribbean se pueden registrar
sin ningún costo y los esperamos a todos
para que participen del mejor evento de
mujeres que va a haber en el caribe y
también del mundo pues ojalá que así sea
y sobre todo ojalá que tenga repercusión
para nosotras gracias a ustedes por
estar en ellas hoy nos vemos
próximamente en france24
[Música]